Our Mutual Friend goes he was a mark
Normand goes dude I was on the road with
Bert he was at to leave after three
weeks he's like yeah I guess I learned
have to go home I go because there were
time out who'd be the fun's gone the
road with my god I feel like Bert right
Bert really be great he goes dude that
yeah I think he said two weeks of two
weeks I'm loosing you know I can't and
marchings all the time he's he was like
to go home he was he was one of the
funniest humans to be with I run so I
run in a fast clip I don't realize it's
a lot of times like the way my brain
operates it's very like I don't know if
it's like panic inducing but like like
I'll get up a workout and then like I
work out every every morning usually I
work out every day on the road because I
just if I don't I feel like I don't get
the toxins out and I feel like I'm I
then I'm [ __ ] up yeah I feel cloudy
and so I barely worked it worked out
with Marcus which meant we were there
was a lot of day drinking involved we
were flying a lot and we get to the
airport and I'd be like I'd be like I
just grabbed us both a beer and he'd be
like oh are we back at it I'm like come
on mark I dude I love that
getting someone egging someone in to get
no drink in the mo come on man
TT doesn't said a big last note line
mark it's just one just one and then we
got a we got him addicted to ambient
like damn yin and then we lost the
ambient drink and he says fall asleep
wakes up he was oh that was amazing that
was amazing
I've ever had it was me and my cameraman
was with me he's so funny and I even
trying I'm not why so funny so dude I've
never heard his brick his bill burr joke
or not joke but his bill bird story know
what is it so he goes he was just just
like he goes to like in LA we all look
up to bill bird he goes and I see him at
the cellar knee he's but he's kind of by
himself and I go burn let's grab a drink
it is let's get the [ __ ] out out he goes
like he goes I've never met him and
burgos likes it that [ __ ] yeah let's
do it
he is so
didn't do this because we had a bar and
you know I don't know they got a little
awkward and a songs planning he goes you
know he says some of us you know they
say the n-word in this song and he told
Burt bird knows music
verse obsessed I didn't know and it's a
some like ac/dc some classic song and
Burt goes all right first drinking us
what do you say because they say the
n-word in this song Umberto's the [ __ ]
you talking about and he goes huh replay
it back and BRR I guess just tears into
him about it and mark says he's like
yeah so he goes I'm so embarrassed cuz I
thought I thought I was like he was I
forgot his wife's black so we get into
he goes he's like yelling at me and he
goes in then it just like fizzles out I
leave he's like [ __ ] because I panic
I leave he was next morning we're doing
press together and I don't want to go I
call my genes like do that one I don't
want to [ __ ] do this thing you're
gonna be fine Berbers a good guy he goes
there and Burgess completely was like
what's up
like everything was all oh yeah that's
so good I got a call from bill I'm on my
way to the fight companion I'm buying
wine and cheese he must have known I was
on my way and he and I just get a call
and it's billing okay he goes I just
want you to know I can feel the cloud of
self-doubt taking you over as you make
your way to the fight companion and she
said bunch of dog [ __ ] he's all yours me
at the cabbie score story he's never
dying thing to me he's just like I'll
call you out it's like it's like a
legend walking through he's he is to me
he's intimidating I think he's the best
comic working so depends what you like
yeah I love him because we want to
access all game together and he goes
what do you guys do nothing to do you
call me good you wanna go next FL game I
was like [ __ ] yeah
so I go this close yeah really close I
didn't know that we have a podcast
together
Gobert toys so we go down to the we go
down to the XS and I'm super gregarious
like I love meeting fans like if a fan
recognized me I get excited also
and I love taking picture that is not
bill Bert Bert what's up good guys
hey man I don't wanna be that guy then
bill goes then don't and walk away so
are we getting recognized and people
aren't recognizing bills he's got a
hoodie on and a hat on and I know he's
not trying to hide that just son looks
really bad he didn't want to burn
he puts sunscreen all over so he's got a
hoodie and a hat on and he's eating he's
eating the pizza and we're walking
through and people are like the Machine
I'm like what's up and they're like oh
dude dude I'm a big fan of oh [ __ ] it's
like yeah and so what boom bird leans
already goes hey stop matching their
energy because you're getting more
excited than they are which is making
this turn into a frenzy yes just say hey
how you doing and keep walking okay dude
we yeah I love Bill he's one of the
funniest my favorite Bill burr story is
this is how quick his brain works right
I'm certain this isn't a bit of his but
uh we're driving in a car one night one
day and I see a van old conversion van
and go I go you know Bill loves
nostalgia like the old thing so I go I
hope it won't matter how cool those were
we were kids how great with conversion
vans with the captain seats he's like
yeah I go whatever happened then he does
that it's a branding issue he's not
writing a joke it's it's a branding
issue this is a branding issue yeah
couple guys rape a couple kids and some
vans and now you can't drive a van
around then he goes Bert
same thing with rollerblades they were
fun for a summer next you know a couple
gay guys where I'm yeah we're rolling
he's not trying to be funny happy but
like but the thing I like about Bill is
Bill wool Oh bill will find a part of
you that's funny that you don't know
it's funny yeah and then he'll point it
out and it'll enjoy it's like we go to
lunch one day I don't I if I see someone
who I don't think English I will say the
English word like four times like
napkins napkins napkins napkins napkins
napkins like just I don't know why
should I get it yeah and Bill's like he
gets it man napkins I go hot sauce hot
sauce hot sauce
we're at this Bart with his chicken
restaurant and then they come and they
go
are you done with everything and I guess
I went like this I go yeah I'm done
Oh who the [ __ ] do you think you are the
Archduke Ferdinand yeah I'm done but I
don't even realize I do it I just go oh
yeah I'm done he'll correct you too I
remember having a conversation with him
back to the comedy store and he said
something I go oh yeah you're correct
the [ __ ] you because I went I went yeah
it's like people sign up the by a
pitbull like you're gonna deal with
pitbull probs yes it's any dog just show
se people's but it's any document get
any dog yeah all right you're wearing
your jumpsuit because you look like a
you look like a mechanic from a musical
yeah I went because I wear a jumpsuit
like Chappelle wears by work before
special came out and I wore it and I was
like I love judge suits so I wore it
from John Varvatos and I went and
everyone's kind of clown on me and you
know Tony Hinchcliffe Rogi and everyone
yeah and then burr walks and I was like
man this is the worst and he says his
line right you look like a mechanic from
a musical and then Rogen the boys jumped
on me and burst stuck up for me I was
like a [ __ ] yeah dude he said something
like oh if you could [ __ ] get away
with you'd wear that [ __ ] so he looks
[ __ ] fine he's a T cosine I'm like
yes shut your [ __ ] mouth
dude he's an interesting like and he
would he would not like hearing this but
he's a very sensitive interesting
thoughtful guy who really cares about
people but he would not like hearing me
say that he is that but you in this hey
Monroe you know the reason I got the
reason I'm where I am today I mean I
might have said about a million things I
go I wish I could pinpoint different
times in my career where Joe kind of
pointed me in the right direction number
one number one is him telling me I had
to tell the Machine on stage oh wow him
doing the oh I told her on his podcast
and and he said this is one of the
greatest stories I've ever heard
he was you got told on stage I said it's
not a story he goes no it is now from
now on I wish I you got the audio of
this I'm sure it's I'm sure I'm
inflating it in my head so I was gonna
fight goes for now on he is only to be
known as the Machine and when he goes
onstage shout the machine until he tells
it I went to Columbus that weekend and
they were shouting the Machine and I was
like guys guys guys it's not that this
is the beginning of the
of death squad remember that early early
stages the there are my guys I'm not
gonna tell him this kid in the front row
goes dead Columbus is like a big hot bed
for podcast yeah Kym the front row goes
hey Bert man tell it
we understand it's not gonna be funny
right guys look is we got to work on it
if it's gonna get good oh wow and I went
what the [ __ ] kind of community I'm
involved in
that's number one number two he calls me
Road and calls me one time I'm riding
[ __ ] motorcycles through rice paddies
in Vietnam high as [ __ ] drunk right I
mean I'm doing travel team I'm on the
flip-flop sits and rode Carlton he goes
what you doing I saw him drunk as [ __ ]
that's high and I'm running running
motorcycles to rice paddies in Vietnam
and he just starts laughing and he goes
this is who you are
[ __ ] Travel Channel this is who you are
and if you're not talking about this on
stage you are wasting your talents as an
artist [ __ ] Travel Channel get away from
it come back to stand up I was like he's
right yeah and then my wife called and
she was like what you are not the
machine you're a father of two get the
[ __ ] off that motorcycle and then cut to
I'm doing my second my last season of
birth I did birth Concord reboot birth
conquer I've been on a Travel Channel
for nine years I'm backstage with Verne
rogue and I walk in and I guess I don't
know if I said something what you see V
this is uh five years ago okay five
years ago almost it yeah probably
almost exactly and i said i don't know
if i said something t v-- ish you know
about like I don't know what I said but
he goes they Brogan just in like in like
that like I can't keep it in anymore
him embargo him in your show sucks huh
and they're like what are you like a TV
star is that what you want to be like a
like a Travel Channel host like the way
they said it was like they're like
you're not you're better than that you
know that right and I was like guys guys
I was like guys I got a you know I got a
family I got and they just Birds just
goes what's your not and I go what he
was how much money do you need to make a
year to pay your bills tell me the
number and I was like and I told them
the number was number was low at the
time I assumed my number is the exact
same number we do today I yeah we don't
have it we don't really buy it but
honest yet but it's still big number
yeah and and burn Rogan they're like
yeah you can get that from podcasting I
remember them being
okay focus on your podcast focus on your
podcast you know will help you get
guests we'll all be on your podcast
they're like get and then you can get
monetized for your podcast and I'll tell
you you can make that from podcasting
and stand up there like get the [ __ ]
away from Travel Channel when those two
dudes [ __ ] that's me from day one
he's been saying [ __ ] acting just to
stand up and punch of course I never
listened and problems yes
yeah in podcast problem is now you know
I never listened then you get a TV show
and then I just sold another show and
then I think I sold another show usually
the problem is that right now no I'm not
bragging the problem is that you when
you're trying not to do something
doesn't want you trapped into this thing
and you have to kind of go yet sit back
and go I'm a comic first and foremost
the just other stuff you came out of it
act like you're an actor I know but I'm
I like stand up tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]